first of all i mean this is such an
iconic film to be able to be part of it
when you found out your cast first
reaction uh excited i probably you know
threw my hands in the air and you know
just uh yeah i'm extremely excited i
can't dance
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's country line dancing hey you
all need to learn some new moves
you're gonna drop me on the daycare
while you go dance with them girls but i
actually did the play in high school
first play i ever did was footloose i
played willard so to be able to do the
movie version is just incredible yeah
overwhelmed and to audition for wren but
then to get such a great character yeah
this has been fun too yeah yeah i went
in auditioning for ren and then she
asked me i could do a southern accent i
said absolutely but inside i always
wanted to be willard i was built for
willard man so yeah yeah grateful
where are you from you talk funny
i talk funny
i talk funny you should hit you from my
end now in the film you have no rhythm
and we're done
[Music]
but clearly if you're gonna play ren you
must have rhythm yeah no i i have a it's
my secret weapon and i actually you know
it's hard to act like you can't dance
when you know that you can and i felt
bad lying to the audience but yeah by
the end of it willard's willard's cut
and loose i need you to hold on jack
what are you doing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
julianne of course and kenny two
fantastic dancers in the dance world
working with them on set first time lead
yeah i mean you wouldn't know it from
watching this movie kevin or kenny has
the uh kenny's got that swagger um and
you know he had really big shoes to fill
uh there's a lot of pressure on him same
with julianne and they just knocked it
out of the park and they're going to
have huge careers their stars all right
now halloween is right around the corner
what is your favorite halloween costume
from your past
i think uh one year i just went out as a
giant pumpkin and i think there's
something refreshing about being such an
iconic halloween image as a pumpkin you
don't have to make it sexy just go out
as a pumpkin right yeah sometimes yeah
a sexy pumpkin i don't know how that
works but you know that could for your
next one any plans for halloween this
year um i might be in china so i don't
know
yeah so i don't know how they celebrate
in china uh but that's that's probably
where i'm gonna be
[Music]
you